Oh [Music]
what is going on YouTube now recently
has described it has not a single if I
hated how do I get out of the singles
club
first off insensitive bastard how would
I'm not [ __ ] you tell me out of all the
questions you could have asked me near
the abdomen who has been rejected by
every single ethnicity on earth hey
what's up there you go there see double
the sibling with me there don't touch me
Wow [ __ ] it well I'm not gonna tell you
that being single is bad because I think
you're young and it's not as bad as you
think it is firstly I think if you're
getting all the things that goes on with
having a serious and committed
relationship no that is not something
that overweight the only cream men say
which I already know what it is number
one when you're single it saves you
money you want to be in a relationship
you're joking [ __ ] you ain't got money
like that look at you trying to spend
money on somebody else when you've got
three dollars in your bank account and a
bag of Skittles I'm not saying that you
have to have a lot of money to have a
girlfriend but what I am saying is that
when you have a girlfriend
somehow your money disappears and I know
some of you ladies are gonna say I only
know matter pay for me up independent
and see that what you say now until
you've all had a couple day and that's
it across from you buy his girlfriend
her dinner because the other do be like
never don't worry I got this one right
and then your boyfriend me like maybe we
split this but you're gonna pay cash
card mmm whatever broke [ __ ] and you
see that's the problem like that because
some of you dudes be aiming away too hot
in the beginning and you forget that
everything you gonna have to top back
baby take this this is an expensive
watch whatever broke [ __ ] the [ __ ] what
I don't know it would you guys let's
make sure that everybody you hang out
with is
the generate and a piece of [ __ ] so she
has nothing to base all hook you up said
it was exactly I'm single i definition
of free time this is only gonna be based
on how she wants you to spend in a
relationship is about compromise and if
you yeah that's already some [ __ ] that
you already hate doing for example for
those guys out there that have been a
real long committed relationship you
know that when you want to have a little
time away from your girl you want to
spend it the way you want to write Rob
get some relationship science for you in
your free time you're about a fun can
I've seen her mount of fun when you all
without her if you have fun with your
boys and there might be some girls
another she don't know she's at home
doing [ __ ] you just might get you ask me
here's the right way to do it and what's
up in man you don't mind you with the
boys you know I'm I have a funny [ __ ]
because you're not here obviously let me
stick a doodle the wrong way whatever
bro [ __ ] dafuq be prepared to be
criticized that's why you ever notice in
the beginning of a relationship the girl
always tells you she loves everything
about you yeah baby just the way you are
gonna change and then she'll say all
your negative traits in a positive way
oh my god baby don't ever lose weight
because I love your squishy belly swag
swag swag watch what happens when you
get that six month mark in everything
that she says to you will change my
friend Emma Khan are you seriously gonna
heat that oh my god your titties are
bigger than mine if I can look like a
homeless person who's [ __ ] himself oh
my god you look like Oscar the [ __ ]
background always had a girl told me I
was breathing mom you had nothing left
to change so I can't breathe the way out
oh [ __ ] it let's play this game I don't
like the way you bleep you know what I'm
breathing wrong cuz you're suffocating
me yeah when you get into a serious
relationship just remember that you have
to be willing to give up a majority of
the single life stuff that used to do
when she wasn't around now if you're
ready to give up that life
me you're ready to be in a relationship
that want to be in a relationship just
because of an age factor thing like you
feel like you're getting all then you're
probably not ready
see age has nothing to do with it it's a
mental thing now if you can't tell them
any harm elationship experiences have
not been too positive I've been
emotionally started am i lonely no I get
to stay in my house all alone in my bed
for the rest of my life it's good we
don't need no woman just touch my just
woke up what I miss smoked one up in the
morning fell asleep with the TV on in
heavy drinker being on phone in yeah I'm
zoning hit that shower with my new girl
where now [ __ ] the neighbors there is a
huge difference between you doing
something because you have to and you
happen to do something because you want
to did it I said it see I remembered it
I don't know what it means yet but baby
don't worry about this I got it right
here
it's receive [ __ ]